[Music]
he
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute but let's do it in a way that
makes the snowflakes heads explode let
me be clear before this podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not give a
[Music]
[__] this is the Tony Michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
you [__] eating [__] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the Tony
Michaels podcast and this is Tony
Michaels hey Tony [__]
[Music]
them dark Brandon strikes
again are you are you are you scared of
some special Council report that proves
that there's no deep State out to get
Donald
Trump oh the Deep States out to make
sure Donald Trump isn't President then
why is the Deep
State writing a report that'll make sure
that Joe Biden can't remember anything
and that he will never be the president
of the United States get the [__] out of
here with this nonsense
I know I know oh my God Tony it's so bad
the narrative is going to be so you set
the narrative you're the one stop listen
stop listening to
MSNBC stop it stop listen to CNN stop it
stop stop listening to [__] people
that can't form narratives stop they
suck at this they [__] they [__] suck
at protecting our democracy with
messaging they they [__] suck at
it and the people on Twitter who have
been deflated and this that you know I
get
it I get it they're like oh man Joe
Biden can't he's old and he can't yes he
yes he's old he's in his 80s
[__] and yeah his memory
probably is not as good as it was 20
years ago who's is do you remember what
the [__] you had for breakfast last
Monday the answer is no you don't
remember and if you do remember you're a
[__] you got it written down
somewhere or some [__] okay quickly and
accessible so you could tell me
otherwise you don't remember you
don't
remember but this this this report
smashes this idea that there's a deep
state that is weaponized against Donald
Trump to make sure that he never becomes
president of the world and Trump of
America ever again
see some
qinon conspiracy theory or some
[__] and if you're scared of this
report then you've been listening to the
media Karen goddamn
de someone pointed out this morning in
the uh producers Corner that our friends
over at Midas Touch have not released
but one video of this I
think they're little
gunshy31 truth and and protecting
democracy with
narrative man it's this is [__] easy
this is [__] easy dark Brandon did
what dark Brandon should do yesterday
and he dunked Ducey in the trash dunked
him in the [__] trash with
sarcasm this is not a question of
Biden's memory listen I and millions of
other people out there would vote for
Joe Biden's dementia ridden corpse over
Donald Trump any [__] day of the week
and twice on Sunday okay his dementia
ridden corpse would be president before
Donald Trump all
right stop being so goddamn down on
yourselves and really honestly stop
being so [__] ridiculous when it
comes to special councils this was why
it was so significant when Merck Garland
appointed a special counsel to the Joe
Biden's documents case Okay the reason
why it was so significant is because we
were going to
guaranteed get a report from the [__]
special counsel it's actually a
requirement by
law by law it's a requirement to get a
report it's in the [__]
statute or as Kramer on Seinfeld says
the stat statue the Statue it's the
sculpture of the of the
[Laughter]
law oh Liberals are so dumb so
snowflakey and I know some of you out
there are probably like goddamn Tony I
didn't have this fire about this issue
until your mouth opened but you knew
this was what was going to happen when
you came to listen to the show why do
you think you come here every single day
you don't come here for so ton and be
like oh God they got us now Donald
Trump's going to [__] win oh man Joe
Biden should just drop out of the race
oh my God forget all his accomplishments
and everything he he's done do you know
that he totally [__] he totally
rickrolled the house go on their border
crisis last week where the [__] were you
on that one huh huh you [__] people
who say Joe Biden's old and he ain't got
a [__] memory he rickrolled their ass
do you not remember this [__] it was
last week it was [__] last week your
memory isn't obviously that [__] good
if you don't remember this [__] come on
man are you kidding me get the [__] out
of here with this memory
nonsense the [__] out of here with this
[__] and get the [__] out of here
with these leftists who can't pick a
position and [__] defend
it pick a [__] position and defend
that [__] like your democracy
depends on it you [__] [__] that's
right I'm con liberals [__] [__]
they need to toughen the [__] up and if
it takes me yelling and screaming every
goddamn day of the week to toughen up
these [__] then that's what
we're gonna do that's what the [__]
we're gonna
do liberals need to be stop being such
goddamn [__]
Jesus [__] Christ for crying out loud
it's not this [__] we don't we don't
have to stand around and argue with
[__] about memory Marjorie
Taylor green couldn't recall over a
thousand times over a thousand times do
you remember Donald Trump couldn't
[__] remember that egene Carol wasn't
Mar Marin
Maples he pleed the fifth over 500 100
times in his [__] civil fraud case he
couldn't remember couldn't
recall Jesse Waters yesterday on Fox
News I'll show you the [__] clip on
Fox News talking about Joe Biden's
memory didn't know that Christy gome
moments later is the governor of South
Dakota not South
Carolina spare me the nonsense okay and
liberals if you can't get out there and
defend this [__] you are a bunch of
[__] derc
[__] I'm surprised that people who
shill for Biden couldn't even come up
with a goddamn argument about the Deep
State it's the only listen it's the only
[__] argument that you need to make
them defend their
[__] you need to learn something
about [__] Warfare
information infow Warfare is super
important and we're getting into this
situation where we have to describe this
type of warfare in
detail and over the coming weeks maybe
maybe we should do lessons in what the
Liar's dividend is there is a thing
called the Liar's
dividend and every time Trump tells a
lie and the left buys into that lie
or the media or whoever he gets a
dividend he gets a little bit of money
in his
pocket sometimes it's real
money sometimes it's Trump money which
we know is not
[Laughter]
real we need to operate on a level of
information where we know what the
Liar's dividend is and we know how it
works because we are losing track and
the plot is slipping through our fingers
with some stupid [__] special counsel
report when this report should be the
only thing that we should talk about to
prove why Donald Trump shouldn't be
[__]
president this special Council looked
through one box of [__] documents at
Joe Biden's house one [__] one [__]
box of documents and exonerated the
[__] exonerated him from any
wrongdoing and the reason why the reason
why is because Joe Biden didn't try to
convince his attorneys to [__] hide
boxes from the feds Joe Biden didn't try
to lie Joe Biden didn't try to obstruct
Justice Joe Biden didn't try to keep the
[__] documents even after they came
to [__] serve a search warrant to get
the
[__] so spare me spare me the
[__] liberals out there that aren't
willing to go to war with this
okay it doesn't take to look at this
issue and I know the White House is
going to be mad they got to pretend to
be mad listen folks this is going to be
a good listen this report is good
politically for Biden it's good
politically for Biden but it's only good
politically for Biden if we the people
out here in the pro-democracy Coalition
set the narrative to where they the
Republicans the Nazis the America first
fascist are on the defense defense we
have to always form our narrative to
make sure we diminish the Liar's
dividend on their side and if that means
we got to have a little bit of liar
dividend on our side fine let's do it
let's be let's be liar capitalist [__]
them [__] them [__] them [__]
them it's what we're gonna do that's
this new political movement this new
brand of liberalism that we're trying to
develop
no holds bar no holding back we're not
we're not only are we going to [__]
punch Nazis we're going to make The
Punchy the Nazis punch each
other okay that's what we're gonna do to
get them crawl back underneath their
[__]
rock it's not for this
nonsense acting as if because Joe Biden
doesn't remember what he had for
breakfast next Monday disqualifies him
for being the president of the United
States well as as a matter of fact if
the choices are Joe Biden's dementia
ridden
corpse and Donald Trump I would take the
corpse every [__] day of the week and
10 times on
Sunday it's so ridiculous that we
[__] trip over $20 bills to pick up
nickels and
dimes this is good for our narrative all
you got to do is think about it for a
half a second and realize that if if
their entire position is that what they
have they have a they formed a committee
for the weaponization of government
against Trump folks they they they come
up with a whole new [__]
committee for their stupid [__]
narrative that the government is
weaponized against
Trump you [__]
boneheads
this report totally [__] undoes that
entire narrative and that plot slips
directly through their fingers with this
report because if the media is supposed
to believe that somehow this report
makes it to where Joe Biden can't be
president and
then V rading radama dingdong proun my
name correctly he's in the news goes on
Fox News this guy is the dumbest
[__] in politics you know I I um
I used to joke that he's going to get
Andrew
yanged I don't know if you remember
Andrew Yang or not you probably don't um
You probably don't but rad damama
dingdong I always figured he was gonna
get Andrew yanged which is he's gonna
get Andrew yanged eventually um but it's
gonna be so much worse it's gonna be so
much worse than Andrew Yang Andrew yang
actually went on to try to run for the
the mayor's seat in New York you
remember that too oh God that was a
[__] catastrophic failure on his part
um but ramit David dingdong goes
on
goes goes on Fox News and says this
report from
special special counsel her is it for
Biden he's GNA have to drop out and
Michelle
Obama's Michelle Obama's going to be the
nominee these people are just completely
[__] obsessed they can't help
themselves oh my god oh [__] like they
can't even they can't even go for the
easy end right like the easy end would
be that Joe Biden he he he somehow
shakes it through this race and then KLA
Harris he resigns the as soon as he
takes office and takes the oath and then
she's gonna like that's the easy road to
a black woman being president right
right that that's the that's like it's
like the wa the free water way you know
what I mean like water is going to find
the quickest in the easiest way
right but the idea that the idea that
that Joe Biden's gonna drop out so
Michelle Obama can be the nominee which
honestly most Democrats are like all
right so what's what's the issue here
what's what's the [__] Pro I mean I
would definitely vote for Obama over
Trump the [__] are you talking about man
you people seem really terrified to
black women you do you seem scared as
hell I mean you should be but because
you know black women do things right
they don't [__] around black women do
not that that's why I believe that that
is the face in the future of America is
black
women Jasmine Crockett is a perfect
example right right have you ever I mean
I've showed clips of Jasmine Crockett on
the show but godamn I mean you just give
her [__] five minutes right and she
cleans house like in five minutes she wh
there that goes there that lie goes she
dunks that lie in the
[Laughter]
trash so I mean I I can't wait I can't
wait for our government and our
governments all around the country
School boards [__] County commissions
state governments the federal government
I can't wait for more and more black
women to get into those governments they
are absolute fascist Killers when it
when it comes to government and they are
they are no [__] right so this idea
that [__] Michelle Obama would
replace Biden because he can't remember
what he had for breakfast last Monday
this is really stupid by the way but
okay what wh why why would we be upset
about that why would the pro democracy
Coalition why would liberals be
upset that that Michelle Obama would
somehow take his place all right and
then we get not only do we get president
Michelle Obama but then then we get then
we get first gentleman Barack Obama do
you know how [__] cool that would
be okay what I mean what's the bad in
this I don't understand what's so
goddamn bad in this in this scenario you
know what I mean oh my God but rad
damama dingdong puts this dumb dumb as
dog [__] argument out there like that's
that's what they're going with on Fox
news is that now that
Biden absolutely dunked Ducey in the
trash because that really should be the
news here is that Joe Biden got [__]
pissed yesterday he got [__] mad man
and he needs to [__] get mad and
[__] stay
mad dark Brandon needs to be dark
Brandon 100% of the time [__] this going
in the Batcave and taking the bat suit
off and then being Bruce Wayne every
once in a while [__] that [__] we need
full on dark Brandon 100% of the time
247 from here on out and I'm not just
talking about up until the election I'm
talking about after the election needs
to go nuclear on these
[__] absolute [__] burn
these [__] to the ground with the
straight [__]
attitude because he did yesterday he
absolutely destroyed the entire the
entire of the argument that he can't be
president because he didn't remember
something the [__] out of here again
Donald Trump just a year ago couldn't
remember the difference between egene
Carroll and his wife Mara Maples you
[__] dumb
[__] he was looking at pictures of him
and he couldn't remember so spare me the
[__] that someone is supposed to
remember every single [__] box they
touched in their garage for the last six
years that's the dumbest [__] I've ever
heard in my life I got boxes that I
[__] haven't unpacked in years that
I've moved three goddamn times should
have threw those [__] away no clue
what's in them when I do go looking them
I'm getting like [__] I forgot I had
this here can't run for president now
couldn't remember what I had in a box in
my garage I guess I'm not qualified to
be hey hey Glenn kersner where you at
maybe we should 14th Joe Biden you know
what I I'm just saying I'm just saying
we maybe we should 14 Joe Biden I think
this disqualifies him it says it clearly
in 14 section
three oh my God the 14th Amendment stuff
that's another group of people losing
their minds because they're like oh the
Supreme Court justic has made
arguments against the [__] that I've
been talking about on social media and
that that's not
fair oh man you people are pathetic oh
yeah I'm gonna say it I don't care who I
piss off I don't care who leaves it's
pathetic it's pathetic that you think
because some guy who used to be a
prosecutor makes a video about the 14th
Amendment section three and says that it
says clearly that if a president who is
trying to be le reelected denies the
results of the election calls on his
supporters and the proud boys to come to
the capital then he tells to go to the
capital and break in and overturn the
election while he sits at the White
House um not calling off his dogs then
absolutely it says that he cannot be on
a ballot especially a primary ballot in
Colorado it says it clearly in there
that's exactly what the 14 section three
says people are [__] wild it's wild
stuff that you think because you can
type in on social media that that must
be what the Supreme Court Justices or
the courts are going to decide it's
really stupid stuff it's really stupid
and to get offended to get
offended that because Glen kersner said
something that makes it the real thing
that it
is be offended I don't know what to tell
you I don't know what to tell you and
and and a lot of people yeah Tony you're
you're knocking on the left well yeah
I'm Gonna Knock on the left about this
memory thing the left is getting this
all wrong their narrative is all [__]
wrong you haven't heard one [__]
talk about the Deep State on social
media I'm sure besides me you haven't
had one [__] make this argument
besides me and the reason why is because
I don't
know I don't give a [__] anymore I don't
care who I gotta please right Jamie I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna form a message
show that the White House loves me okay
I'm not GNA make videos on YouTube so
the Democratic establishment loves me
I'm not going to I'm not going to not
attack someone for lying to their
audience like Glenn kersner did and like
Neil Cel does and like MSNBC does I'm
not going to sit here and not call that
out because they're lying I'm not and
you can be mad at me that they're Liars
that's fine but I'm not gonna do that
[__] I'm not gonna do it I'm not gonna
do it I'm gonna do what the [__] I want
to do and I'm gonna make a message that
you guys can carry around and [__]
win for our democracy not win some
[__] points with some corporate
sponsor somewhere because I said this
certain thing that people want to hear
that's what they're doing by the way
they're saying the [__] that people want
to hear that's what they're
saying and they thought yesterday that
the [__] that people wanted to hear was
Joe Biden's memories bad so Michelle
Obama should be the
nominee it's time for Joe Biden to step
aside get the [__] out of here with this
Joe Biden step aside [__] it's the same
media again that last week [__] was
racking up clip after after clip after
clip of how Joe Biden [__] called the
Republicans Bluff on a non- Christ
crisis at the border and [__]
Rickroll those [__] Rick Roll
those some
[__] [__] they won't even they won't
even they won't even bring a bill to
committee you have you have Co political
right-wing political commentators
threatening United States
senators [__] James Langford that the
the aliens the admitted black alien suit
from Oklahoma that [__]
Nazi he [__] said it on the floor
that commentators were threatening him
can you imagine that the power on the
right wing that a
commentator could [__] call a United
State Senator think about this for a
second think about this and we're
worried about Biden remembering what he
had for breakfast last Monday a
right-wing commentator more than likely
um probably
it's I I would I would guess that it's
either Dan
Bonino um Shan
Hannity Tucker Carlson someone like that
right this whoever called and threaten
Tucker Tucker sucks James
Langford James Langford is a sitting US
senator okay yeah it could be Laura
Ingram I mean there's there's a lot of
guesses and it may have been more than
one it may have been more than one but
my my guess is it's probably someone on
Fox News and my guess is it would
probably be like
Hannity that's what I'm guessing because
Trump probably absolutely gotten
Hannity's year and told Hannity or
someone on Fox News to call and threaten
Langford because lford was at the heart
of this [__] bill right think about
this for a second though think about the
nuts that it would take on the rightwing
in the rightwing for a commentator to
call a sitting us Center and threaten
them not to fix a problem that they say
is a problem right think about that
think about the [__] nuts on these
people and then you have the left who
won't even [__] who can't even muster
up enough [__] courage to build an
argument that absolutely is going to be
a a political windfall for Biden with
this with this her special counsel
report Folks at exonerates him it shows
a picture of one box in a
garage that he forgot about because it's
in his
garage this is you want to talk about
kitchen table issues ask people again
when they say well J Biden's memory say
what did you have for [__] breakfast
last Monday they're gonna be like I have
no idea I don't remember and then you're
gonna and then you're going to ask do
you have boxes in your basement that you
haven't looked through in years yeah
what's in them I want to know every
single piece of content in every single
box in your basement right now start
name in the inventory give it to me give
it to me give it to me give it to me
give it to
me seems to be a
theme they won't do it they can't do it
because it's stupid it's dumb listen
dude had mounds of boxes he was hoarding
boxes he was hiding boxes in the [__]
from the [__]
feds okay if the Deep state is after
Trump and it's weaponized against Trump
then in this report you have to believe
that it's weaponized against Biden
too the Deep state is weaponized against
dark Brandon because dark Brandon is the
most effective president of all time he
will Deliver Us advances in Social
Security and Medicare he will make sure
that Americans don't go broke because of
a medical bill godamn he's going to get
decent [__] wages for the American
people how dare he the government must
weaponize against dark Brandon we must
fight against this evil that is the
dementia ridden guy in the basement who
can't tie his shoes and can't remember
his name ah doesn't make any sense give
it to me give it to me give it to me
this is [__] weird don't go anywhere
we'll be right back I promise right
after
this what the [__] is wrong with you
people it's a rhetorical question at
[Music]
best we'll be right back on the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast fellow Patriots what would you
do if there was a trump supporter right
in front of you crying in pain because
they have to live under communist
tyranny we know what you would do you'd
reach out and give that true American a
hand now here's your chance for only $50
a day you can help us help those true
Americans recover from Biden's socialist
reign of terror these are those Trump
supporters and this is that moment send
your donation via venmo to the real
president Donald J Trump it's only $50 a
day recurring and it means you'll get
these Trump supporters the critical help
they so desperately need to survive
under this false regime please donate
now because those Trump supporters you
just saw can't wait another
moment [__] them [__] [__] them [__]
[__] them [__] we're back to the Tony
Michaels
[Music]
podcast w welcome back to the show it's
Friday Friday Friday Friday and the guy
with the last name Sanchez I believe is
going to be here today that's right
we're gonna do bone head of the week I
apologize I'm really sorry I didn't get
the um poll out on Discord I put it out
on YouTube I think but I didn't get out
on
Discord I may have been stoned last
night I think I was I think I was stoned
[__] I was really
stoned we got some infused cheesecake oh
my God and the cheesecake you you know
you can't really taste it because you
got to eat that much at least I don't
I'm kind of a lightweight when it comes
to infused cheesecake and I didn't
really remember I didn't I didn't
remember that we needed to do Bon head
before I ate the little nibble of
Cheesecake I didn't remember you ever
you ever forget I forgot dark Brandon I
had a dark Brandon moment I had a dark
Brandon moment but the economy is okay
you know what I mean like the economy is
okay bone end of the week was only on
YouTube but the economy is okay it's
okay because when you have dark Brandon
memory problems you got dark Brandon
economy problems which are good problems
to have they're good problems to
have they weren't gummies it was cheese
do I do um partake in gummies though I
haven't had gummies in a
while um we just got this cheesecake not
too long
ago and you know there is a danger in
having infused cheesecake you know what
I mean like there's a huge danger in
there because if it
really if it really um Mike says nibble
my ass you want me to nibble your ass or
you're saying it was it wasn't just to
nibble you lying bastard it was it was
just I mean it's just a little piece you
don't need much my
late lightweight ass does not need much
and I have cheesecake memory loss Gary
says listen there is nothing wrong with
getting high okay this listen this show
may be a little less interesting if I
didn't partake every once in a while you
know what I
mean it it might be
it might be more boring um shyd says
just a nipple yeah want a nibble it was
a nipple a nipple of Cheesecake that's
actual um official measurement of
Cheesecake is a nipple a nipple of
Cheesecake oh boy oh boy oh
[Laughter]
man well speaking of biting off a piece
of ass dark Brandon absolutely laid into
Peter Ducey yesterday I'm not going to
waste much time giving you this clip
here it is Biden getting pissed off and
throwing sarcasm around like it's um
like it's cheese it's nipples of
cheesecake in a Cheesecake Factory once
listen oh thank you and I'll take some
questions President Biden something the
special counsel said in his report is
that one of the reasons you were not
charged is because in his description
you are a well-meaning Elder man with a
poor memory I'm well meaning and I'm an
elderly man and I know what the hell I'm
doing I've been president I put this
country back on his feet I don't need
his recommendation it's totally bad is
your memory and can you continue as
president my memory is so bad I let you
[Laughter]
speak my memory is so bad I let you
speak and that just shows you right
there that dark brand
should be dark Brandon 247
[Music]
[__] how in the [__] the media didn't
take that moment and go well [__] the
memory
thing [__] the memory thing but they
were like no no we need to we need to
have memory porn all [__] week oh
yeah Joe Biden's memory sucks oh memory
porn for two
weeks Donald Trump just lost $83 million
cuz he [__] grabbed een Carroll's
[__] he sexually assaulted he [__]
raped EEG Caroll and lost 83 million
[__]
dollars the House GOP just [__] the
bed on their [__] lion ass nonsense
about the border and how it's a
crisis [__] the [__] bed because Jo
Biden called their [__]
Bluff okay you [__] ignorant ass sons
of
[__] to believe that this moment
right here wasn't the point where Joe
Biden absolutely destroyed any kind of
narrative against any stupid [__]
report that any special counsel would
put out about his [__] memory and how
it would or wouldn't qualify him to be
dark Brandon is the dumbest [__] I've
ever heard in my
life and they can go [__] themselves
every last one of them and anyone who
isn't standing up saying the [__] I'm
saying can go [__] themselves too
because you're G to get some of these
dumb bastards on the left going oh man
this is the moment where we can swoop in
and take the nomination from the guy who
won a WR in by 60 [__] percent in New
Hampshire stomped whatever Mary Jane and
Philip Dean whatever the [__] their name
is in South Carolina you people are a
bunch of dumb
asses listen listen to me when I tell
you this dark Brandon will be the
[__] nominee it is how it works the
super delegates are never going to turn
on an incumbent president when he has
the record that dark Brandon has and by
the way the record that he's willing to
defend because he stood with the
American
worker I don't know if you [__] I
don't know if your memor is good enough
for that I don't know if you got dark
Brandon memory problems on how the
president of United States stood on the
[__] picket line with the goddamn
American workers to make sure that labor
was the key to this country's [__]
economic backbone it's the reason why
our [__] stock market's so high it's
the reason why unemployment is so
goddamn low it's because the American
president stood with the American
working class you stupid [__] and that
ain't got a goddamn thing to do with his
memory because he didn't forget about
us he didn't forget about the American
worker that's for goddamn
sure so you could take your memory
narrative and stick it up your [__]
ass all the way up in your [__] ass
and anyone out there who isn't defending
defending what Joe Biden's record is at
this point because these stupid bastards
want to talk about his [__] memory
then you're derelict and you're Duty and
you're a bunch of [__] [__] you're
a bunch of [__] [__] if you can't
[__] come up with a goddamn argument
I talked about it yesterday man I talked
about it yesterday pick the best
position you can pick and [__] defend
it
[__] defend
it and defend it with some goddamn
passion instead of [__] being so
goddamn boring into the microphone into
a godamn camera say [__] every once in a
while you [__] [__] start cussing
start getting passionate get some
[__] FCC violations for cursing on
air it's enough of this [__] our
democracy depends on it and you're going
to dance around trying to figure out how
to [__]
defend Joe Biden because he doesn't
remember what the [__] he ate on Monday
for breakfast you people are a bunch of
[__] and yes I'm talking about the
[__] left here and everyone always
gets all upset at me Tony you're
attacking the left because they suck at
this they [__] suck at
it Jesus [__] Christ if people would
just [__] listen for a half goddamn
second and stop being a bunch of goddamn
snowflakes we wouldn't have these
[__] problems my ass wouldn't have to
sit in front of this microphone and yell
and scream every goddamn day I would I
would be able to do all kinds of
different
[__] we wouldn't have these [__]
fascists trying to take over our [__]
governments if the [__] left would
get some [__] [__] a attitude every
once in a goddamn while
maybe just once a week would be
nice CU I know there's a whole [__]
band of people out there that are sick
and tired of the left being such [__]
[__] they're the left sometimes is
more of a [__] than the [__] on Donald
Trump's
neck oh Tony don't use that word [__]
[__] [__] [__] [__] [__] [__] [__]
[__]
[__] get offended get mad at me go say
it somewhere go tell
someone go tell Glenn that you're upset
that Tony Michaels calls him a grifter
go tell them over at midest touch to do
some videos defending the [__] record
of the guy who can't remember what he
had for
breakfast go tell him go tell them to
stop censoring the [__] FW you
[__]
[__] it's enough of this [__] and you
shouldn't [__] you should be [__] mad
you should be [__] mad that they're
not doing their [__] jobs don't be
mad at the [__] special counsel don't
be mad at the that's what the [__] go
yeah be mad at the special counsel for
doing his [__]
job the special counsel job is to write
a report you dumb [__] that's
his job it's a requirement of the
special
counsel and if there's really this deep
State weaponization then why the [__]
didn't merri Garland squash the whole
report in the first place because
Merrick Garland could have redacted the
entirety of this [__] all of it all of
it Merrick Garland could have redacted
every [__] last bit of it he could
have redacted and he
didn't
so spare me the [__] nonsense that
Merck Garland and doj is weaponized
against Donald Trump spare me that
[__] and spare me the [__] that
we can't [__] form narratives and
arguments to win [__] democracy every
goddamn day of the week and keep these
[__] fascists on their heels keep
them on the defense
but Tony they'll just lie who gives a
good
godamn then expect their [__] lies
see their lies point out their lies mock
them for being liars and let's create
some [__]
[__] for crying out
loud that's another narrative Snowden
says
Comey the left said this [__] almost
immediately Comey no it's not it's not
Comey this case is closed it was one box
in his garage he let the FBI come in and
get it he called him and said come get
that we found it come get it he didn't
hide it from them he didn't obstruct
them he didn't he didn't [__] stand
back and and and in the secret part of
his [__] little phone his his little
phone calls tell his lawyers to [__]
hide [__] and move boxes and lie to the
feds he didn't say any of that
[__] there is no Anthony Weiner laptop
in this Joe Biden story
folks there isn't they want it to be but
there
isn't the reason why Hillary Clinton
[__] up the whole Comey thing cuz she
did that she did
that she didn't tell the American people
hey I'm cooperating fully here's how
we're going to do it Joe Biden
did Joe Biden did everything that Donald
Trump and Hillary Clinton should have
done all of it he did exactly what they
should have done and they
didn't that's right I'm knocking on the
email lady but if you if if you don't
remember it then maybe you need to
refreshing your dark branded memory
because you're not remembering clearly
how how [__]
ridiculous the Clinton campaign and
Hillary Clinton tried to make the issue
of her having classified information on
a server when it was an important issue
that she could have handled the
appropriate
way just like uh I don't know the
[__] the guy with no memory who has
dementia who can't who can't figure out
what his name is he couldn't figure out
how to handle this issue
correctly it's almost like people don't
remember
huh [__] memory you know what I mean
[__] out of here with this
[__] what do you want oh you thought
I was gonna come here today and knock
the special
counsel that's what you thought you're
like oh Tony's totally Gonna Knock the
special counsel today he's totally gonna
tell us how the special counsel is wrong
and he definitely shouldn't have said
this and said that I can't stop the
special counsel from saying [__] I can't
stop the [__] report from being
released these are not things that I
have power over nor do you you do not
have power over these things dark
Brandon doesn't have power over these
things that's why government isn't
weaponized against Trump because dark
Brandon couldn't stop this report from
coming out because don't you think if
don't you think if Joe Biden could steal
a [__] election he could stop this
report from getting at in out into the
open I mean I think he would I think
democrats should be able to manage that
right so [__] dumb it's so [__]
dumb and I'm so glad that you guys
appreciate um the narratives that we
have out of this show and I and I know
you um a lot of you come here every day
because you're seeking something that no
other media Outlet is going to tell you
that no other media Outlet is going to
have the narrative that we're going to
have here that they're going to be
terrified to say the [__] we
say they are they're going to be [__]
just terrified of
it but we're not we're not terrified of
it I'm not scared to [__] offend a
few people I'm not scared to make people
mad I'm not scared to attack where the
attacks need to happen so that [__] gets
done just I'm I'm not GNA stop doing
what we're doing here at the [__] them
fam and I and I'm so glad that all of
you are in 100% um and and the reason
why is because not that you agree with
me 100% of the time because I know I
know most of you don't agree with me
100% of the time that's not the design
that's not how democracy works that's
authoritarianism if I was like well if
you don't agree with me you're booted
man you're booted you're booted I mean
someone yesterday
someone yesterday who is a loyal viewer
of the show decided to send me pictures
of Shaz on grinder or some [__] I don't
know what it was but these are pictures
that they're all over the Internet you
can find them they decided to drop that
you I I don't normally check my DMs on
Facebook that often like maybe once a
week is how often I check my
um this is how often I check my
my my Facebook uh messenger DMS and now
I'm not going to Che them at all maybe
because someone decided it was a good
idea to send me
pictures that are on the internet of
shazz on grinder I I don't know what I
don't know some some um gay porn thing
that Chaz is into it's fine Chaz it's
good I think you you know honestly from
the [__] pictures Dude any any guy is
[__] lucky to have you you know who
goddamn man you you got a talent and
your talent is not to [__] be a troll
in the Facebook you should I mean you
should really think about going pro with
this whole porn thing I'm just telling
you holy [__] I mean hunter Biden might
even be jealous my friend I mean I had
it all wrong yesterday I thought I
thought I figured you'd have a little
wean but Jesus Christ but this person
decides to put chaz's dick in my [__]
DMS right holy
[__] holy [__] I was like come on you
know of course you know I had to go
bleach my eyes afterwards because that's
not the kind of thing I'm
into I you know I mean when I'm watching
porn and I know this is kind of a little
bit too much information but when I'm
watching porn I you know I want to you
know I want to see some action you know
what I mean I want you know I want to
see some action I want to see you know
her guts being rearranged a bit you
that's what I like that's what I'm into
I don't know what you're into but that's
what I'm into that's what I want to
see but I I don't normally like to look
at the underside of some guy's schlong
you know what I mean like I'm sure
that's what Shaz is into because um you
know most of the time I would figure
that if you're making porn for other
people to look at you're probably going
to make porn that you would like to look
at unless you're a Prof Prof shz and you
would you know know what other people
want to see so I just say um you know
the angles of the pictures you were
taking for grinder they made it look
humongous and I don't know if it's
actually that big or that's some kind of
camera trick but I will say I will say
my friend if your size is anywhere close
to the truth and the DMS that was sent
to me yesterday dude you should go pro
you should [__] you should get out of
my comment section and really focus on
how to get into the porn industry my
friend you can make a hell of a lot more
money legitimate money um you know
making sex tapes than you could taking
Putin's money to get into the comment
section of left leftwing shows I'm just
saying just a bit of advice for um Shaz
not The Shard Army because I'm sure most
of The Shard Army has little bitty
Weenies and I mean ity bitty ity bitty
weenies ity b ity b you know they can't
compete with Hunter Hunter Biden's
Shaz though man I'm I'm going to give
you props man I'm all about the truth
Shaz and you got a huge dong dude I mean
if those pictures were real who baby any
who stop sending me [__] shaz's dick
and DMS please is the moral of the story
give it to me give it to me give it to
me I wouldn't I would almost rather look
at neck [__] than chaz's [__]
so next J Tony how did you go how did
you go from Joe Biden's memory to to to
neck [__] and Shaz dick that's how we
do it here on the Tony Michaels podcast
we don't [__] around so um the the other
thing too is to all the people on
Facebook you can know you can no longer
make fun of
um um shaz's dick size either because
I've outed him I doxed him I dip doxed
him
oh sh you stupid bastard one of these
days you're going to listen to the show
long enough one of these [__] days
you're you're gonna be a liberal again
and you're gonna be doing [__] the
best gay porn that money can buy I have
a feeling that's my uh that's my two
cents of it
so
H someone's saying I might be a pole
Watcher I'm not the pole watcher I'm not
the [__] pole Watcher someone else
sent me the [__] picture of
it and surprised me and it was not like
a good surprise like surprise Oh yay
it's a get no it's [__] picture of
Shaz holding his [__] that was not cool
you know what I mean I don't want to see
that
[__] what are you gonna
do what are you going to do uh Cynthia
says porn is shaz's side gig well if
it's not anymore a sh be Cynthia Cynthia
should be I'm telling you Shaz should go
pro he should he should lay off the
whole Trump thing and just go pro and do
gay porn like a [__] even if
you're not gay anymore chance they pay
good money for straight guys to do gay
porn I
hear I don't know if you can look into
that I'm sure you're you know you have a
talent agent somewhere
so oh boy and see you can't even you
can't even yeah know you can't even
acknowledge that you got a huge dick
like I'm sitting here bragging on you
man and you're like Tucker charlson did
a great job
yesterday speaking of big dick yeah
Tucker Carlson did do a good job
yesterday of making a fool out of
himself and the rightwing is so they're
such they they do you know they buy into
um some of the [__] [__] the
narratives like the leftwing does you
know they always stepping on rakes again
they used to not step on as many rakes
with their narratives but they do
they're like yeah but actual journalists
too uh interview Vladimir Putin yeah but
they don't go to Vladimir Putin and to
the palace and [__] give him a BJ or
whatever they had to do that Tucker
Carlson had to do to get the [__]
interview that ain't what they [__]
do they arranged the interview at a
[__] place for Vladimir Putin to get
his voice in on American television it's
called
journalism it's called Journal
journalism what what Tucker Carlson did
yesterday was xchan porn is what he did
and really honestly if you watch some of
these videos of the Tucker Carlson
Wladimir Putin interview and Tucker
Carlson knew this and we're g to cover
this in Bonet of the week a little more
in detail but what Tucker Carlson did
and he knew that what happened is is you
Vladimir Putin does not speak English on
camera right he doesn't and I'm sure he
speaks a little bit of English but he
doesn't he do really he doesn't speak
English on camera
ever um and and that's intentional right
um but tuer Carlson knew that there was
going to be
translations right so all a person has
to actually do to [__] you know to
[__] manipulate one of these videos
is just cut the translator out of it and
then put another voice over that
translator to say whatever you want and
Tucker Carlson knew that that's why he
asked the questions why the way ask him
and that certain questions that he did
ask about Nazis and Hitler and [__] like
that um so people would make not only
fake videos in favor of the left so that
way you can say oh they see it's a fake
these people are fake and they're trying
to bait lefties into buying the fake
videos right that's one of the purposes
of it and the other purpose is to make
it make it be whatever they want it to
be on rightwing in the [__] deep dark
places on the web where the the [__]
toothless spread necks gather up the
Cheeto humping [__] nuggets hostages
they'll believe any goddamn thing any
goddamn video that's put in front of
them he knows
this he knows
this so speaking of big old dicks Tucker
Carlson is a big old [__] traitor is
what he
is I mean [__] Tucker [__] him but you
know I I'm sad to see
that he had to make he had to make Putin
porn for xchan because that's what that
was was Putin porn you know we got Trump
we got Trump trump crack here uh in
America here let me show you some Trump
crack yeah I got one I'll show you one
here really quick it's Trump
crack Trump crack no it's a thing um we
we play around with Trump crack every
day like the uh the neck [__] thing
that's Trump crack um when I make a
thumbnail with Trump on it that's Trump
crack right grab him by the neck [__]
so you gotta understand that um in in
the world that we live in right now in
this stupid [__] timeline that we
live in um people are going to click and
be more agitated because even just the
sight of [__] of the fentol fury face
is visal right so when when when you're
in this commentary game like I in and
you guys listen to me every day the idea
is you want to be visceral right that's
the whole object of
commentary um and a lot of times you
know whatever you're trying to pimp to
your audience whatever it may be um
because we get to pick right me as a
commentator gets to pick or the producer
of the content gets to pick what the
subject is right um so I mean that's
um that that's the rub right so we as
commentators or we as content creators
whatever you want to I don't I I mean I
consider myself a content creator but
really I'm a Content
Thief if you noticed that but we just
like like um on Twitter when I show you
clips of like Newsmax or Fox News like
Rob Phil owski or AC or Aaron they're
thieves they're thieves they they're not
they're not standing I mean it's not
like Rob Ron Phil Kowski of the editor
and chief at minus touch did you know
he's DeSantis Republican did you know
that I don't know if you knew that lot
people get pissed off at me when I speak
out against someone but um he's a
DeSantis he was the santis guy he was
des santis and point on point D that's
why he get he gets so [__] hard up
about the Santas anywh who any that's
kind of a s I digress but it's not like
Ron Phil kowsky is standing with a
camera at every single one of these
things right that's not how he's going
online and he's ripping video like he's
stealing it
right I mean yeah Luke you can call it
whatever you want you call it a Content
recycler or whatever I don't whatever
makes you feel
good whatever makes you feel good about
it right but it's the reason why a lot
of people don't like my show and the
reason why is because I'm able to create
two hours of content with just me
talking like that terrifies content
creators if you want to know the truth
it terrifies them a lot of them actually
come to the show to learn how to do it
and I've taught people how to do it you
guys know some of the people who do what
I do every day on the tubes of
you it's very hard there's very few
people that can do it how sparks does a
great job he can keep an audience and he
can keep talking he and now now Hal uses
probably more video than I use um I'm
I'm more of a Storyteller type
commentator but see Hal is a comedian
first and then he's a commentator I'm
not a comedian I'm just a commentator
that's it and I see myself as that not
necessarily A content creator because we
steal it we steal it [__] them it's the
Internet it's the wild west man and
we're transparent about it we're
transparent I it ain't like I'm like
when I'm telling you guys hey I'm lying
to you we're pretending here I'm
transparent about it ain't I when I'm
really when I'm when we're when we're
trying to work a narrative and we're
trying to work a narrative that's really
honestly based on misinformation and
we're GNA pretend a little bit I tell
you that right I'm transparent about it
I'm not trying to [__] trick you or
fool
you that's the whole point like when we
do AI we I don't I'm not trying to trick
you I mean sometimes you get tricked but
that not my intention always sometimes
maybe in a little
bit little bit
sometimes but I mean a good instance is
a Taylor Swift video right people were
mad you should take this down she would
be upset I don't care if Taylor's upset
that I made an AI video about her it's
AI what it's not actually her okay and I
made it I know that it's
fake but it brings me back to the Trump
crack because Trump crack is real WE
Post Trump crack all the time on the
channel when I find a [__] clip
especially if it's [__] def fting all
fear her saying some dumbass [__] man
we'll clip that and throw it on the
YouTube channel because that's some
Trump crack and that's Trump crack that
everyone needs to see sometimes you got
to do drugs you know what I mean
sometimes you gotta do [__] drugs and
sometimes you're overdosing on Trump
crack sometimes you're
overdosing and this this piece of Trump
crack that I'm going to show you here
this is an overdosage of trump crack yes
it's Glenn yes I'm so if you're offended
if you're offended Tony I don't like
when you say stuff about him I don't
give a
[__] oh my God if you're not aware that
I don't give a [__] what you think about
what I say or what I don't say you
haven't been here long enough and
honestly if you're not getting mad about
some of this stuff or you're not getting
mad at me a little bit then I'm not
doing my job I need to get people a
little pissed off every once in a while
we got to use this strategic out raise
to point it you know what I mean we got
a a democracy to save here we can't be
[__] trying to stand around deciding
what Tony can and cannot say Jesus
Christ I mean you know you might hate
this segment that I'm about to do but n
just wait bone end of the week's coming
in here soon Gabe Sanchez be here before
you know it and be oh thank God Tony
shuts the [__] up and lets Gabe
talk this guy with the last name Sanchez
on Friday man it's so so good that he
comes in it really breaks up the
monotony of Tony repeating himself Time
and Time and Time Again knocking on the
host insults his audience while
repeating himself for two
hours what the show is godamn it that's
what the show is goddamn it it's info
mment I'm not scared to call it that
either um so this is a video this is
Trump crack see the Trump crack here see
how he puts see how Glenn puts the Trump
crack in there but I noticed something
about this video and I'm going to show
it to you this is about the 14th
Amendment and what the arguments were in
the Supreme Court and how Glenn kerser
he's so smart he's such a good lawyer
but he didn't see these arguments coming
I don't I don't know why the [__]
everyone think I mean I think Glenn is
smart but I don't know why everyone
thinks that he's the expert on this
[__] topic and I don't I really don't
know why Glenn thinks he's the expert on
this [__] topic because this guy this
guy didn't see any of these arguments
coming that every everyone everyone who
can read who can like [__] memor
remember what they had for breakfast
right this is like dark Brandon memory
time you know what I mean dark Brandon
memory
time but this guy apparently glin
kersner does
not cannot figure out what the arguments
were going to be
against the 14 section three in this
case [__] weird you know what I mean
I figured he wouldn't oh yeah a lot of
people left all the Glenn fans have left
it's about a hundred of them about a
hundred of them all all those Glenn fans
left that's okay they'll come back for
boned maybe I won't be talking about
Glenn then but see you you're you're
totally missing what I'm trying to say
is that the reason why Glenn is saying
this stuff is it because Glenn doesn't
know what the arguments were going to be
okay that's not what it is Glenn is
saying this stuff so that you'll watch
his videos right and he's saying it
because he wants to say the stuff that
you the audience even though it's lies
want to hear that's called grifting
that's what that's called when when the
right wing does it we normally call it
grifting that's that's what that's we
call Elby things Stephan Moore says I'm
still here el el think Stephan Moore
must must like Glenn must like Glenn see
that a lot of a lot of content creators
like Glenn a lot of them like Glenn
right because there's an opportunity for
Glenn to be on their show or for Glenn
to talk about something that they did or
something like that or to be friends
with Glenn on Twitter Glenn follows me
on Twitter Glenn follows me on threads
he does he follows me on those places
and I talk bad about him so I give him
respect for that and I'm here yapping my
trap and calling him a grifter and he
still follows me I respect him for that
you know I give credit where credit is
due Susan says Glenn fans still here
yeah Glenn fans unite I'm just saying
I'm not saying all the content he makes
is bad I'm just saying he uses Trump
crack to Griff
people who watch his content you just
got to be aware of that right you can be
a fan of Glenn and be aware that he's
he's grifting a bit because this is a
grift here listen to this here let me
let me make this bigger there we go do
you know what my main concern is with
what unfolded in that courtroom today
nobody do you know what his what Glenn's
main concern because I'm sure I'm sure
those justices and the court really give
a [__] damn about what Glenn's
concern
is now he's speaking like this and the
reason why he's speaking like this let
me tell you why he's speaking like this
the reason why he's speaking like this
is because he's speaking through him for
you right like that's that's the that's
the tactic here right so I'm I'm
breaking it down of why Glenn is saying
what he's saying how he's saying why
he's writing this because Glenn writes
this stuffff he clearly writes this
stuff okay this is not him making this
up on the Fly Like I Do here right I
really grinds my gears I make all kinds
of [__] up right and when I mean make it
up I mean sometimes sometimes it's say I
and sometimes it's not real but I mean I
I I I don't have it pre-written down now
I I know someone else who is a great
content creator he's a great content
creator and he he loves to have
everything down like perfection
which is not my style I like sloppy okay
I like it sloppy baby oh I like it
sloppy Slappy Jew you want
it but there's a guy there's a guy that
I know with the last name Sanchez is
also a content creator he's going to be
really uncomfortable because I'm
attacking Glen kersner but it's gonna
happen why would it be uncomfortable yes
he's not g he's not gonna be mad that's
great I'm GL I'm happy I would care dude
I don't people got hot takes people got
dumb takes people got good takes people
got bad takes you know oh yeah how many
sometimes people what yeah on your your
mic which mic are you working off of I
think you're working off the one in your
ear um you gotta switch it you got to
pull the old
Switcheroo um so no I I'm not saying
that all Glenn's takes are bad but I
want to know what your personal opinion
about your takes are so what do you
think do you think what's your
percentage on of your takes that are bad
like are that go south you know what I
mean I can't hear you you can't hear me
now I can yep now I can hear you okay uh
if I'm gonna be honest I don't listen to
Glenn I don't listen to Glenn either
what I don't listen to anybody but no
what I'm say what no what I'm saying is
you is your own personal takes what
would you say a percentage that are bad
are they in
the no no I'm sure I'm sure I've had bad
takes uh I'm trying to think like what
are bad wait wait what did you you you
said I'm I'm sure I've had a bad take or
two yeah yeah you know it's life I'm
sure I've had a bad come on man all
right all right I want to tell you sorry
are you talking specifically like with
my show in this show or is he saying
life just just anything in general
anything in general but mostly your
political commentary how many of your
takes are horrible or bad how many of
them are I don't know that's a good
question I've never you should
be I don't dwell in the past I uh it
happens and then I move on move forward
to if I do look if I if there is
something like a guy who loves a soda
stream I'm just gonna I mean I love a
good bubbly water that's one of your bad
takes by the way that's one of your
horrible okay I mean some some people
wait Soda Stream over coffee give me a
break come on man that's a hor some
people say that because I don't like
coffee I'm not a real human people are
saying some people are saying some
people many excuse me excuse me many
people are saying okay many people are
saying that they don't like they don't
like that I don't like coffee okay
they're saying that they're saying look
there's a lot of I don't like cream
cheese I don't like sour cream what the
[__] right get the [__] off my cream
cheese [__] wrong with you man dude
give me give look give me a bagel give
me a bagel no cream cheese please please
I'll e I'll eat a bagel cream cheese do
you put peanut butter on the
[__] at least yeah like if it's
like a bagel I'll put peanut butter on
or I'll make a PB&J or whatever but I'm
not I'm just not I I used to eat cream
horrible take horrible take
I used to eat cream cheese as a kid and
then at a certain point I just stopped
just like I stopped drinking
milk I just I just grew out of it just
wasn't something I was doing what do you
mean grew out of drinking milk is it
like is milk a kids drink is that what
you're saying no you know what happened
I it's a it's a like a guttural like
memory that I have I was in I believe it
was K kindergarten and I we had like our
you know our little like lunch or
whatever that day um or like it snack
time I had a glass as kids would do in
kindergart yeah yeah yeah you know it's
snack time miss those days though I'm an
adult I could do that anytime I I do
snack time all the time what are you
talking about I'm
like where's the FR I had a glass of
water and without me knowing it another
kid poured in his milk into my water
didn't look at it drank it and then all
over and since that time I have never
been able to have I mean like look I I
once had food the first time I ever got
food poisoning was when I was in France
performing we went to go get um to get a
quick meal before our show and turns out
uh that I I got sick from the meal we
performed the show luckily I was like
not [__] myself on stage we leave we
go to dinner I'm like oh I can't I can
like barely hold down any you know
whatever Oh I thought you were saying
you could barely hold the [__] like you
had to go no I mean like I in the
restaurant I was like puking and
[__] I was like oh my God please
don't come in this bathroom um and so so
then what ended up happening is I got
sick right so for the next like week or
so I'm traveling around France and Spain
and I'm like oh God I'm like so like I'm
recovering slowly uh coming back to
normal and again I've never had it
before and I go back and I was like well
what were the things that I had that day
earlier that day we were in Paris and I
was having me and my partner were having
croissants we're having this we're
having this roll and all this
stuff that is what my body associated
with for a year and a half I could not
touch or look at a croissant even though
the croissant didn't get me sick I
couldn't have the croissant so I all
right all right I got to know before we
move on because I'm sure this is another
one of your shitty takes here but I'm
gonna ouch you on this chocolate
milk I'll let me one up you chocolate
milkshake you won't do a chocolate milk
shake no no I no no I will do a
chocolate milk shake I won't do a
chocolate milk oh my God man horrible
takes all day long look I was I was
gonna give you like I was gonna give you
like 95 96% of the time gabes goty good
takes but now with all this chocolate
milk
no milk I'm 880s now in the 80% is what
I'm thinking W look man look chocolate
milkshakes are my that's like goto
whenever I'm like uh what what in the
[__] is the difference between a
chocolate milkshake ice cre what right
but I mean it CH maybe some peanut
butter you know it's great you know
because this is what I'll do if I'm like
hung over I'll be like I need some like
greasy meal get a burger some fries boom
chocolate milkshake so what's your go-to
what's your go-to burger for
hangovers like a like a maybe a double
Smash Burger what the [__] is that
where's that from uh you can get it
anywhere but I mean like LA's really big
on Smash Burgers this where they put it
on the press and they oh I got you I
thought you me guess you think here like
you could think of a Smashburgers like
Wendy's are pretty thin like that's kind
of but not really but like what you're
like look here midwesterner let me tell
you what a smash that's why I love
Wendy's because it was french fries
frosties and the and the real real
unfrozen meat oh [__] will do a
frosty but he won't do a chocolate milk
hor hor
horrible takes all day long horrible
horrible horrible horrible takes
horrible takes EXC me excuse me excuse
me many people are saying that Gabe is
right on this okay look at the chats
look at the chats okay [__] the chat
listen EXC me many in
the that's what they're saying in the
chats lighting up
okay bing bong bing bong speaking of
Bing Bing Bong in bad takes uh Glen here
and I always have the best [__] I
pause it at the appropriate times Glen
here um he has a horrible take on the
14th because he's like he's like I am
really concerned that the Supreme Court
made the arguments that I knew they were
gonna make I mean alls I had to do was I
don't know [__] use my brain my
thinky space and know that they were
gonna make these arguments he act like
he acts like that no one thought that
they were going to make these arguments
which is [__] ridiculous but then
watch what he does with the glasses I'm
on to something here watch what he does
with the glasses how dramatic this is
watch he pushed back on the fact that
Donald Trump engaged in Insurrection
what are the
consequen our constitution of somebody
who engaged in Insurrection That's it
man did you see that did you see that go
back again watch watch watch what he
does watch what he this is the super is
it because he's about to read this
parchment paper watches an insurrection
the [__] glasses man that dude I was
like I Ser hang on I seriously I'm like
I need this is what I need to do like if
I just like look how much smarter I look
man I'm gonna say that you're at least
15 points higher from that right bad
takes not so much but the glasses I mean
look look at that look how much smarter
I look when I got the [__] glasses on
and then and then you
you're so smart now now your bad takes
are from like 86 up to 92 now just with
the GL I mean it's crazy it's like when
people are like oh British people sound
more intelligent because they have an
accent right right right like just so so
like the thing is is like it's like this
and he's like and it's
like you you remember He-Man
[Applause]
right and the sword it's almost like
Glenn when he pulls out his glasses is
the like the content like levels up
right and like the viewers cuz I almost
had an orgasm when he did it when I
watched the video I was like oh oh oh
godamn I had an information orgasm you
you could say that those spectacles
really touched your testicles right well
I mean honestly it made me believe the
[__] that he was saying more is what
I think it did and not that I thought he
looked smarter or that he was smarter I
was just like well maybe may I mean no
one is going take out a pair of glasses
like that if they're bullshitting me
like watch in Insurrection no way this
guy is feeding me a line of [__] but
I also I'm like is because obviously in
the moment he's gonna read off whatever
he's he's gonna read 14 section three
again again he's gonna read it again I
do love how it's like I'm gonna read and
then this like old scroll comes
up what's supposed to be the
Constitution here watch no person shall
hold hold any office under the United
States who yeah no person shall hold the
he can read I guess that's he's got his
glasses on so he can read all right keep
going buddy who having previously taken
an oath to support the Constitution of
the United States shall have engaged in
Insurrection Donald Trump is
disqualified by the Plain language of
the Constitution no he no he's not no he
no he's not no he's not that that
because the Supreme Court says he's not
that's also you know what there's a part
of the Constitution that probably talks
about like the separation of powers and
the Supreme Court and the decisions that
they make there's probably a part in
there that Glenn's forgetting maybe
maybe we should go point that one out to
him maybe he should go grab that one and
read that one to his audience it's so
[__] dumb uh what ER for the audience
can you do you think that there's any
downside to this case being brought
before The Supreme Court other than the
fact of like Donald Trump is not
disqualified
right we all even even left leaning
judges on there you know if you listen
to the arguments that were made
yesterday while there was some
concern you probably wouldn't be
surprised if they're going to go
unanimous on this decision you know is
there any well maybe 81 but I I don't
know if there'll be anything more than
that no I think I think I think I think
it'll be I think it'll be
unanimous it's it's gonna be like oh the
S of my she's a traitor like okay um
because Brendan here says really because
the scotus says so well I mean again
that's that's how it works like I'm
pissed off about the RO v Wade decision
and the dobs decision to overturn roie
Wade but that's how it [__] works man
we're not we're not [__] we're not
storming capitals and creating
rebellions because they overturned roie
Wade because people respect the rule of
law and that's that's how our
constitution works that's how it works
that that's how it [__]
works uh is it what's the word um you
know legal precedent uh you know that's
but that's what it is right and that's
what it comes out to be when scotus
makes a decision whether we like it or
not obviously we would love for Donald
Trump to not be on the ballot because
why should it you know and a guy who
incited Insurrection and wanted to
overthrow the government and overturn
the election results like that is
something where're like you shouldn't
have a second chance at doing that thing
again even though he's talked about
being a dictator okay going to be a
dictator dict taster dict okay got taste
gotta taste
taste right in his neck [__] right in
his neck
[__] oh God it's if there's any one
defining character it's either Donald
Trump's hair or the the puss maybe
that's what he was talking about he's
like I'll get them but excuse me okay
they love him when I grab him by the
[__] okay grab him by the [__] grab
him by the neck
[__] love a good saggy
neck anyway uh Naomi asked did the
decision come out no it hasn't but um
it's not going to go well for the
Colorado it's not gonna go well for for
Chrome Dome Glenn here um it's not it's
just not gon to go well for them and
then he's gonna make a video like I'm so
disappointed I can't wait for you to
watch this entire video and the entire
series of videos of trump crack that
I'll make after this even though I knew
the result of the Supreme Court decision
I knew exactly what their arguments were
going to be and I've been lying to you
this whole time that I didn't know that
I thought that it would go our way
because the because Gabe the the 14th
Amendment section the clearly states
this clearly if a former if a president
of the United States denies the election
and does not concede and then he calls
the proud boys to stand back and stand
by it says it clearly in there and then
he he has a speech at the lips and
whereby his supporters go to the capital
break in threatened to hang the vice
president of the United States he
doesn't call the National Guard he sits
back at the White House lets this happen
um and then all the while the speaker of
the house and the the leaders in the
Senate organized to where they can get
the riers and the insurrectionists out
of the capital so they don't overthrow
the government so that way they can go
ahead and have the joint session and
certify the results for Joe Biden it
says clearly in section three if you do
that or if you try to PR you're not
eligible it says that clearly in there
right I mean there was I mean because
the other thing too is there what I mean
there was like oh we you know this
hasn't been a thing for 155 years you
know yeah because no one's ever tried to
do this before we never elected a
[__] a a goddamn dictator for a day
so yeah no one no one ever thought hey
maybe we don't you know but but I think
uh one thing that was brought up and has
been discussed afterward is like okay
does Congress get involved in do we
change that's the other thing that
pisses me off when they say that
Congress has it says in if it says it so
clearly it says the word Congress in
section three it says it in there it it
says it in there now to be clear we were
talking about this in the producers
Corner this morning before the show and
I know we got to get to bonehead and I
don't know if you have a heart out but
we we'll go fast with bonehead okay it's
pretty fast uh we'll go pretty fast it
is it's a quick it's a quick winner yeah
it's a quick one um it's a quickie it's
a quick
sty said I was perfectly long okay very
quick 15
seconds so um what was I saying by the
way oh yeah producers Corner producers
Corner this morning someone asked about
the 14th Amendment and it is upsetting
that we can't just use the 14th to get
rid of [__] traitors you know I I
agree I but it doesn't state it so
clearly that we can just start taking
people off the ballot and I think that's
where people get this wrong and I think
where the Supreme Court got it right and
their arguments were [__]
eviscerating the Colorado Supreme
Court's defense is that you're talking
about a ballot you're not talking about
an office you're talking about a ballot
yeah these ballot these ballots just
because someone wins on a ballot doesn't
mean they can take that office and the
perfect example is the last time the
14th amendment has been used against an
insurrectionist which was Coy Griffin do
you remember the name Koy Griffin you
remember this name the Cowboys for Trump
guy he was a county commissioner in New
Mexico he held a County Commission seat
while he was an insurrectionist and the
federal judge said no you don't you
can't be a county commissioner anymore
and the federal judge 14 his ass and he
was immediately recused of his role as a
county commissioner and they had to
remove him and there was no appeal they
couldn't appeal it because they properly
used the 14th Amendment to unseat
someone who was in office currently
because he was an insurrectionist you
cannot while holding an office that you
swear an O to the United States commit a
rebellion or they will 14th your ass
they did it to Coy Griffin so now why
why does that matter with Donald Trump
it does matter because Coy Griffin was
[__] convicted he was convicted by a
jury which is the thing that courts use
to validate their decisions going
forward is convictions not indictments
indictments are are just evidence
against someone to um where where they
charge them it is not a conviction so
and I oh but a court codyy but a court
in Colorado right but a court in
Colorado said that not a court not a
court that is part of the United States
Judicial System yeah that's the
difference and you need to recognize
that when you're talking about these
issues and I know I know it feels good
that Glenn gives you crack that you want
to hear but it's just crack it's just
crack it's just drugs that's all it is
as long as you see Glenn's content as
the drug drug that you want to have and
want need even though it may not be the
full truth all the truth and nothing but
the truth so help you the spaghetti
monster in the
sky just recognize that all right bone
head of the week is that what we want to
do I think bone head of the week Bonet
of the week see look at that transition
dude that was so smooth you know the
only way I know is when the little
yellow line in the middle comes up I
know I know I know well let's ah [__] it
let's do the
song
[Applause]
bone head of the week I'm so glad to
have you back for boneh of the week guy
with the last name Sanchez we missed you
last week I know was like where Sanchez
I'm like hey we'll get him on next week
don't worry I was on set I was on set I
could you were on set were you filming
were you filming gay por
MZ
look I signed an NBA with Chaz I guess
they broke it I'm look I'm
not did I dick do you look I'm not
saying but many people are saying okay
I'm not saying but many people are
saying that Chaz was on set last week
doing a little naughty
NY well someone dm' me pictures of
shaz's dick off grinder I think is where
it was yeah unsolicited was it him M I
mean did he s did he send you them no
man I mean unless unless he's using that
some U sock puppet account uh no pun
intended on the sock um but I I will
tell you if these pictures are real off
grinder of shz he's got a hunter coock
like it is huge I don't here he's here
to answer questions he's here to answer
questions and I don't know if it's like
I don't know if it's like uh the angle
that he was taking these pictures that
but holy Hunter Biden's hog baby so and
I've been telling saying has that oh
dude huge [__] huge [__] and I don't
know why he didn't brag about it in the
chat you know what I mean like brag
about Rail and his boyfriends and [__]
in the chat with that huge member I mean
I if listen I think you should go
professional and apparently if you what
you don't want to do what do not do not
Google Shaz Max
Porn Shaz Max
Porn I'm I'm not gonna not gonna no one
no one everyone's like okay Tony move on
move on enough about chaz's
dick oh margorie Taylor green can be
obsessed with Hunters but I can't be
obsessed yeah that's true you can't dude
can't
do all right well let's be obsessed with
these Bone Heads of the week speaking of
Mars I think she makes a special
appearance today Bone Heads of the week
representative comr pile we just heard
from him Tucker
Carlson and the all fear her Donald
Trump uh who would you start with I want
to start with um comr pile what did what
did he do this week that well other than
the fact that he keeps saying I've got
all the I've got all the evidence guys I
hun bid coming in h b I got all the
evidence uh besides the fact that he's
saying that he's now trying to go after
John Kennedy or sorry John krey uh what
yeah John Cary yeah dude well let's
let's take a look here why he wants to
[__] I got the wrong button let's see
which one he wants to attack John Gary
here for let's listen yeah this is more
evidence of obstruction the White House
is obstructing our investigation look no
one knows what John Carrey Authority was
no one knows what John KY uh was
negotiating wait wait are we impeaching
John krey now he is he the Secretary of
everyone what is he the Secretary of I
know my orcus is a secretary of the
border and that [__] the bed so what is
John krey the because John krey was a
secretary uh was a Cabinet member but I
believe it wasn't it wasn't under this
President Am I Wrong am I what hey man
look if you've ever been associated with
Obama like you ever like showed up to a
party shook his hand maybe even utter
the words Obama and Biden Obama Obama
okay Obama gonna go Barack Hussein Obama
Obama's Nation more like Obama Nation um
so anytime anyone has ever said spoken
uttered the name Biden Obama whatever I
think they're just like automatically by
default they get to impeach them they
impeach yeah they get to impeach and
he's like what am I what am I where
where am I right now that I'm getting
impeached like doesn't matter doesn't
matter home impeached most people are
like who's John I mean it's 2024 most
people are like who's John KY I mean
most of the time like you would remember
John krey you know like 2004 2008 you
know is like pretty much the prime of
John krey I'd say right and then he was
working with Obama so that gets you in
the the first term of that
Administration that's what get you imped
that's what gets you so pretty much so
like 12 12 to 20 years ago he was like
relevant within an Administration or
running for president and now everyone's
like he's just like a private citizen
impeach him impeach him impeach John KY
all right let's here the cabinet level
position that he just created but he but
yet he was never confirmed by the Senate
so no one knows really what his job was
but we know he went over there there a
lot we also know Rob that he was
colluding with these left-wing
environmental
organizations okay go back look at Rob's
face here either Rob's got a huge fart
he's holding or he has no clue what comr
pileo is talking about here which do you
think it is I think he's holding in a
fart probably probably he's like just
can we cut to can we cut to a video I
Really gotta let this out right I mean
if you guys ever see me on camera I'm
like that I'm I hold in a lot of farts
here on the show I'm not gonna lie
sometimes I go to commercial in the
middle of the show that's usually
because I got a big one to rip you know
and I don't want I don't want the
microphone to to catch I don't want the
hot mic to catch my fart you I don't
want any more fart Gates happen you
don't you don't want the hot mic to
catch a hot right a hot hot warm fart
right I don't need anymore makes sense
that makes sense so what in the [__]
this I can't believe you people didn't
vote for this guy to be the bone end of
the week with this stuff I don't I don't
think people really knew I don't think
they did either because I didn't know
this um I'm gonna mute him because it's
almost Dumber um when he's muted than
when you can actually hear this look the
guy has and this goes back to points
we've made previously which is the
Republican party they have nothing to
campaign on this is something I I
recently said on my show like Oh I
thought you were gonna say he has no
evidence oh well he has no evidence
that's for sure that is 100% for sure
but what I will say is when you look at
and again this is like uh a point that
I've made in the last few weeks which
is Donald Trump well okay Joe Biden has
like three Jo Biden Joe Biden has three
pillars that he can campaign on one is
covid right healthcare related the the
health of the Country
Financial pillar which is the economy is
on an upswing inflation is down things
are becoming more affordable things like
that right that's a Financial Health of
the company and then you've got the
border which was like the last the final
pillar which is like if you've got those
three things underneath Biden when it
comes to running for 2024 re-election
it's in the bag if he were to get the
border which is a thing that the
Republicans have been whining about this
whole time you know just like they were
like oh the the Biden corrupt family
this and that they had no
evidence when push comes to shove they
you know they can't talk the talk right
they can't they they they can't walk the
walk of what they've been spitting out
and then the border is another example
which is the health insecurity of the
country Biden saying I will do like give
me a bill I'll sign it it comes across
my desk I will sign that so we can get
them the resources and funding like
let's do it and the Republicans like oh
no no we don't want to do that we don't
want to do that and it's the same thing
here it's another example of Republicans
having nothing to campaign on because if
they lose everything that they that they
had which was pretty much the border at
this point because the economy was
another one um that's that's another
loss against Donald Trump if you if you
compare the numbers I mean if you if you
look at an employment rates between
different demographics you see across
the board those numbers are higher under
under Biden and they were under Trump
right and Donald Trump go oh there's my
African-American I love black people
well look at look at the employment
numbers just look at those just bare
numbers of facts right there that's
that's that dark Brandon economy
though the boy know that dark brand is
some [__] man so James comr right here
is desperate and so what they're trying
to do is trying to find anything to
associate with Democrats be like oh well
he had this one position at this one
time and he said this one thing and it's
like you're trying to make you know
nothing something out of nothing really
is what what's going on here and you've
got no evidence no points anytime anyone
ask you you say we're working on it
we'll find it hopefully we hope
so it it's it's a it's the talk of a
desperate man and a desperate party who
have no policies no platform no actual
agenda other than we hate everyone who
isn't white religious in a
man period that's pretty good I mean
that's that's pretty good
of of what it is now let's let's move on
to our next Bon
head um Donald Jessica Trump the fentol
fear her now there is a
thousand um reasons why this guy could
be on bone of the week what the hell
were you thinking because you were like
Trump because I think Tucker Trump and
then there's a few others but you were
adamant about Trump what was about Trump
because he admitted there was an
Insurrection inter erection yeah he said
he was like he's like Nancy Pelos had an
erection she had an ere Nancy Pelosi had
an erection all right well let's let's
watch the tap he said let's watch the
tape see if he says she had an
erection I think it was an Insurrection
cused by
n this was an Insurrection if it was
Insurrection
guns prosecutors have brought gun
charges against at least three
Insurrection so far Christopher Alberts
accused of taking a loaded handgun into
the capital is calling for the overthrow
us your duty over that yet Democrats and
dishonest people in the media every
single day Trump of waging an
Insurrection refit is accused of
carrying a handgun at the
capital that's a gun I think that's
armed every constitutional right to
carry a weapon weapon a weapon also said
many others around him that day were
armed with
they had
weapons there's even a photo and I'm
trying to I'm trying to see if we can if
I can find it but there's a photo he
thinks it was an Insurrection HH he's
finally ad I told you he said he se he
thinks it's an Insurrection man it's an
erection it's an erection so big so
magnificent so powerful Insurrection
Nancy Pelosi really knows how to get him
going I've never I've only had a
mushroom size erection never an
Insurrection they are saying that Shaz
Max though Shaz Max has such a huge hog
it's an it's an Insurrection and he
loves to
insurrecto what what I find uh funny
about the I mean even though it's been
debunked and proven that uh there were
people that had guns right I mean even
on the chatter of the capital 6 or the
the Capitol Police they were said we got
guns we got this guy this guy's in a
tree over here with the [__] gun the
thing that I need people to understand
is you're going to tell
me that every
other
uh Rally or Riot or political protest
whatever you want to call it leading up
to Jan 6 where people literally brought
they're like we're a local militia I'm
I'm holding this AR-15 it's my god-given
right you're gonna tell me you're gonna
tell me right now that people were
[__] they were they were [__] uh
set up to the n they had everything at
those political protests and they didn't
show up to Jan 6 with any get out of
here you're going to tell me the one the
the political protest that they say the
the riot which it was the Insurrection
that really mattered to them this was
the this was the end man if this if they
didn't get this one Trump is through so
you're G to tell me of all the leadup
like mini games like scrimmages that
they had with everyone else and they had
guns at those that they're not going to
bring one to the [__]
championship the
championship the ship baby the ship
speaking of um grandpa poopy pants the
fent and all fear her being on bone head
of the week since he didn't win I've got
a consolation prize for you okay I have
a picture of him feeding his neck Gina
here his neck [__] is he taking a [__]
well he might be taking a [__] like what
is he sitting on a garbage can yeah sure
why not this is real this is a security
footage outside barago here I think I
mean it looks pretty legitimate to me
some people are saying some people are
saying this is real that might be the
security footage that Eric Trump told
Sean Hannity about after Mar Lago was
searched by FBI he said we got security
footage that proves that the FBI was
planting stuff oh really and they
were're like oh yeah you want to show it
and he's like well you know looks like I
lost
connection speaking of pipe bombers is
that what you said pipe bombers I
thought you said bom I thought you said
speaking of pipe armers Mar Taylor green
is the alpha cook now there's a couple
different reasons she could be the alpha
cook this week but the one let's see I
think I've got a video here that I want
to show you uh there's only one you
need
petty petty
ye are you talking about the um um are
you talking about the the video of her
um walking in a hoodie with a backpack
in Washington DC is that the video no
that's another one but I'm sure if you
compare I'm sure if I'm sure if you
compare that gate to the gate of her
leaving the committee hearing yeah after
Garcia was like let her know it was me
uh that moment I think if you compare
the Gate of both both individuals AKA
both margar Taylor green they'll find
that they are a 100% Direct
complete
indisputable match well let's let's
watch I've got a video here of um Margy
Taylor green running away um I'm not
sure what this is watch let's watch the
petty Yeti run away from a
guitar I love
you she's got sty she's got she puts the
Liberals in there she's got stron horse
legs I love
don't hook up with that doll you love
me please sex
to have a nice
night go
[Music]
go oh my
God come
on this guy's my new best friend Robby
Robbie Robbie Road steamer he's my uh
he's my new best friend now
yeah this machine kills fascist you know
Woody Guthrie has a guitar or had a
guitar he's dead now um but he had a
guitar and on and on the and on the
guitar this says this machine kills
fascist and I just believe that Robbie
here may be channeling his inner uh
Woody as I do with my new
tattoo have yeah it's not done yet I'm
going back next Saturday to finish it up
um and we're gonna have that phrase on
I'm getting the Statue of Liberty uh
later next month on this side so uh yeah
but
you might be the only person that has a
Statue of Liberty Tattoo that I'm like
yeah that's good that's real they're
really there's something that are really
bad it's not that it's really bad it's
that a majority of the people who have
Statue of Liberty tattoos or American
flags or like whatever it might be right
are all these magot idiots that come on
like I'm a defender of the Constitution
you're like name one amendment that
isn't the first second and fifth the
problem with a maggot a Cheeto hump and
[__] nugget having a a a stat of the
Statue of Liberty it's like it's the
exact opposite of their ideology like if
you go to the plaque at the Statue of
Liberty and it says get me you're tired
you're hungry you're
poor like like we we want we want all
those people to come to this country
like we want people to across that
imaginary line like we want them yeah
it's almost like it's a like there's
this island you know Ellis Island and
there was a whole it was a whole
experience of you coming in starting a
new
life opportunity this was the land of
opportunity it was the you know the
American dream and yes Republicans look
at that plaque and they go well first
off they probably look at that PL and go
sorry what does that say I can't read
but the second one would be who is this
socialist [__] right who is this
socialist woman standing in this Harbor
with a torch uh to the golden door of
opportunity it says that on that but
those so what I say is those people who
get tattoos of those things that are
supposed to be patriotic American you
know hold those values so dear and true
are the people that stand the complete
opposite of those things well it's
probably they literally have the the the
uh a living a living embodiment of
contradiction well um maybe it's because
they have a the memory problems um like
Joe Biden and they don't have the dark
branded memory that he has U and they
just forget things I I don't recall
tweeting that now
I don't I don't recall making those
threats against Nancy Pelosi and other
MERS in Congress don't remember don't
remember I yeah I'm sorry I I don't know
I have no idea no idea I don't recall
saying all of this oh that dark band of
memory oh man does this have the one
where she's like oh wait wait wait I do
remember that carefully it says marjerie
Taylor green was an American flag and it
says ret retweeted as I retweeted it I
am don't remember don't
remember I don't have this Twitter
account anymore oh no oh no I don't
remember don't
remember I don't
remember I don't recall apparently now
apparently the new fod in Washington is
if you don't remember something then
you're not qualified to hold office but
you know another person that I think is
pretty pretty relevant to the I don't
recall or I have a bad memory who said H
Maga Mike Johnson really magga Mike
Johnson is a dishonorable mention this
week what did he forget he forgets a lot
but what did he forget this week on
Sunday I believe it his last Sunday he
goes on to Meet the Press and he had a
bit of a confusion oh really he he was a
bit confused okay he got he was like oh
this country that country I I don't know
wait wait wait wait are you saying are
you saying that magga Mike the the
wiener of the house mro Johnson the wi
of the house
mson are you telling me that he has dark
Brandon memory problems and we're gonna
have to disqualify not just Marjorie
Taylor green but we're gonna have to
disqualify magga Mike for forgetting
things I mean he's gonna have to go dude
he's gonna have to leave there he's
let's fth Amendment gotta go out of
office you're
totally there anymore the dark Brandon
memory amendment is what it is because
that's you know if if you if you have
any kind of memory lamps at all and you
misstate something or something then
then you must go let's listen well let's
make a couple of things clear here
Kristen know we passed the support for
Iran uh many months ago three months ago
did he say he supports Iran I thought
that's what like he supports the Ron
that's you think it is let's back it up
Kristen you know we passed the support
for Iran oo baby Maga is now in the Iran
Camp H seems kind of convenient I now I
mean it really I wouldn't be surprised
if this was actually something that they
think about at night and jerk off to and
the reason why is because they jerk off
to Putin you know what I mean
like and anyone who loves Putin should
love Iran right I mean I mean Putin
pretty much funds a bunch of terrorism
through Iran um I don't know if people
know that but yeah it's kind of crazy I
don't know if magga Mike knows that or
not go ahead it's almost well I was
gonna say it's almost
like if you remember that Republicans
always say the quiet part out loud now
or that the fact that whenever they're
talking about something they're really
projecting their own issues and
controversies and and and uh and
problems and so this might be another
one they're like oh I wanted to fund
Iran but I actually gave it to Israel
like maybe that's what he was trying
like like I wrote I wrote I wrote in the
margins oh this this should go to
Iran oh darn it darn darn those kids
those meddling kids if it weren't for
them then we would have en Meed
Secretary of the Border my orcus because
that's the that's the other reason why I
think he's the bonehead of the week yeah
which is also why margar Taylor green I
mean they went in they went in in in a
concerted effort they found their you
know they put their their uh whatever
clout they had together and they were
going after mayorcas and they thought
they had it and turns out they don't
know how to count but that's not
surprising because that's margerie
Taylor green that is rough that they
don't know how to count like they should
be able to count I think they said that
Johnson was like oh yeah marar Taylor
green is like the manager of this vote
like is is the one that's in charge of
getting this
together and are we all that surprised
that this was the outcome you're putting
someone who who
thinks that there were taxes during the
Ice Age she on multiple occasions
doesn't know how to count she has she
struggles with any number that is over
six digits okay once you get into the
seven digits Mark she's like [__] um
million that's why that's why Maga and
marer Taylor green and Donald Trump and
everyone else have a really hard time
understanding that 81 million people
voted against Donald Trump they didn't
vote for Joe Biden I mean some did but
also some voted against Donald Trump the
majority of them said no to Trump and
yes to Biden and the margin between the
two the difference the Delta between
those two they have a very hard time
understanding how many millions of
people that is and they think that it's
possible that there was some large
conspiracy but when you remember that
margar Taylor green doesn't know how to
say a seven-digit number and this has
happened multiple times you're not
surprised that she doesn't know how to
count even for three digits yeah to 216
cuz here it
is let's
go on this vote the Y's are 214 and the
Nays are 216 the resolution is not
[Applause]
adopted what a [__] loser and
failure is it possible to be more more
of a loser than Kevin McCarthy um well
because I believe we just saw it
apparently apparently it is um when you
have the dishonorable mentioned Mike Ro
Johnson the winner of the house as the
dishonorable mention this week and the
winner of bonee head of the week which
is not completely surprising Tucker
[__] Carlson Tucker Carlson
Tucker [__] Tucker Tucker sucks is the
bone end of the week and of course we
know why Tucker Carlson is the bonee
head of the week because he went I
apparently went and
um gave shazm style uh introduction to
um to Putin did he [__] Putin or did
Putin [__] him what do you think or is
it like a BJ is it like [__] that
you have you have to give to get you
know you go to the Kremlin and you go
you got to do a lot of favors yeah it's
funny to me this uh this Putin porn on
xgen like they're all jerking off to it
you know what I mean like yeah Tucker is
so strong cuz he went over and and he
cow out to a [__] murderous dictator
and his lies like okay what do you
mean he owned Putin I mean by owned it
do you mean he went all the way back in
his throat and got balls deep into it or
how do you mean yeah there's a lot of I
mean there's a lot of there's a lot of
people I know Ben Shapiro made a he had
a commentary he's like um I'm going to
he's like I'm not going to judge the
interview before it happens okay he's
like I'm you know I said this on my show
last night I was like totally fair you
don't want to judge a book you know by
its cover but in this sense I think you
can like you know the character and the
history of Putin and you know the
character in the history of Tucker
Carlson and you know what they've said
about each other or how that Russian TV
uses Tucker Carlson how Tucker Carlson
helps promote conspiracies uh is
pro-russia anti- Ukraine so when it
comes down to it you could probably
safely assume that most of the
conversation is going to be a oneway
dialogue and it turned out to be that
way where where literally
anytime whether Tucker Carlson thought
he was gonna have a a word in at all it
wasn't until like the ve the beginning
in the very end because it was the final
question when he asked about the the
Wall Street
journalist and then pretty much was like
okay we'll just I guess we'll just
accept the fact that you say that he was
a
spy like that's really how it Ed he was
like okay I want to make it out alive
you know right well I mean yeah yeah you
don't want to you don't want to get
pushed out you don't want to get the uh
balcony balcony treatment you know what
I mean like balcony s they're like
Tucker is gonna stay in Russia for the
foreseeable future right right well here
the other thing that I think um Tucker
knew which isn't hard to know is that
Putin he speaks English and he
understands English but he does not do
it on camera and there are certain
reasons for this why Putin does not
speak English on camera um you can
probably figure out why but Tucker knew
that that was going to be the case so it
was going to be easy to make these
videos fake now this is a real video
here this is really part of the
interview um but the sound may be
doctored now Tucker Carlson knows that
he's that that Vladimir Putin is gonna
have to be dubbed over with English for
anyone on xgen to understand it because
most people on xgen don't even
understand English let alone Russian
yeah
there there are there are a lot of
people on xchan that probably understand
Russian maybe I'm doubting right like
listen listen Tony I have a whole Army
of people who understand Russian a whole
Army on xjan that they love they love
when you speak at speak the Russian they
love it okay they can't get enough need
more more more more but but Tucker
Carlson clearly knew that this was going
to be dubbed um and that anyone with any
kind of sound editing skills at all
could just rip out the part where the
translator starts to speak and just drop
in whatever the hell they wanted Putin
to say and here's an instance of one of
those let's watch what do you do about
it I mean Hitler's been dead for 80
years Nazi Germany no longer
exists and so true and so I think what
you're saying is you want to extinguish
or at least control Ukrainian
nationalism but how how do you do
that
this question appears to be subtle it is
quite
pesky you say Hitler has been dead for
so many years 80 years in fact he is
still here alive through a combination
of Russian science and Wizardry he lives
beneath us in the depths of the
Kremlin so I mean any any person
watching that would think maybe that's
[__] real I mean it sounds like it
sounds pretty if I I mean I watched the
interview last night and it sounds
pretty close to the voice that was used
cuz it's not like an American transl it
is a Russian so that you hear they have
an accent they're Russians speaking
English translating so it sounds pretty
close to what the actual voice was so I
can understand how people would be
thrown off and I mean again this is one
of those things like it's not you know
they're like oh we got to worry about
def fakes you just have to worry about
somebody killing the audio and dubbing
over with something else people have
been doing deep fakes for years all
right and this guy this blue check mark
gets really upset this is fake he did
not say that Community notes uh it's so
hilarious that they beg Elon who posted
[__] huh who posted what this I don't
know some guy's got a Ukrainian flag in
his profile if that dos you anything um
the point is is that the righties get
really upset when when when uh people
believe the fakes right and and then of
course he posted something that says he
said that right after he said this so
let's
listen we are not gay you brainwashed
idiots sucking dick is the normal
punishment for those who have misbehaved
or behaved inappropriately towards
comrades in arms still Shing it sounds
real to me does it sound real to you
that was the response to that guy yeah
that was the response to the
guy I [__] love the internet man I
[__] love the internet I would
probably say knowing how people are when
they're so bigoted it's because they
have their own insecurity or you know
they they they suppress their own
feelings on something so the fact that
there is this kind of Russian conspiracy
of the only reason they're against gay
people is because they're gay and that's
the punishment they put like I wouldn't
be surprised if that was true you know
like that's the type of people that are
out there where they're like I'm going
to punish everyone else because I can be
my true self you know well I love that
this guy calls out Community notes and
then it's a fake and then he gets dunked
on and he gets dunked on I love it I
love it and you know what I love8 for
this right God damn it this supposed to
be the truth Elon says
every Elon and he's like go suck a
dick he's like oh yeah I forgot to
include this part right oh my God so
Tucker Carlson out of all of our great
candidates here for Bon of the week he
gets Trader of the week gab Zen JZ
Trader of the week Tacker Carlson wins
the contest let's give him his
[Music]
[Applause]
due
oh Tucker Carlson you're a [__]
treasonous piece of Putin [__] that's
what he is [__] Putin hump
humping oh boy well that's been Bon head
of the week I'm glad you joined Escape
Sanchez I'm glad you joined us don't go
anywhere though I want you to like pimp
some stuff right after right after the
music stick around
[Music]
[Applause]
music
Bon of the
week great great bone head of the week
with Tucker [__] Carlson wait I gotta
look smarter i g look smarter I look
listen listen you can believe me because
I wear my glasses on the end of my nose
when I read stuff okay I'm GNA read it
to you in the video and uh I look smart
like this so gab chanz tell tell us how
smart your show is and when that smart
show is oh man my smart show which airs
on Tuesday Wednesday Thursday from 5:00
p.m Pacific 800m Eastern it's an hour
show come by check it out you know other
shows happen at the same time that's
totally fine you pick and choose you
know you you know simoc cast baby but
I'm at the same time
youtube.com gab Sanchez are go to I amab
sanchez. for a year and a half or look
during the week
oh for a year and a half I could not
touch or look at a croissant that's true
for a year and a half I could not look
or touch at a croissant I it was a
visceral reaction I couldn't have it
that is what food poisoning it's
terrible the body's a crazy machine man
let me tell you but this is what you can
look forward to this weekend I'm gonna
have at least one or two what was that
episodes coming out one is gonna be
about Tucker another one probably about
Mary Taylor green I've got a list I got
a list you got to put your glass on now
you got to put your glasses you got to
look smart they won't listen to you
unless you put your glasses okay okay
give me one
second
okay so the first one is border
hypocrisy another one is Elina harber
can shut her mouth another one's Boer is
even dumber than we all thought another
one's James Carville Nancy mace marer
Taylor green um Mike Johnson Rona
McDaniel being broke and also this this
uh oh yes hany and the slea guy who who
mugged a man pretty sure we witnessed a
hate crime in National TV and then of
course we've got ourselves this Putin
Putin Tule Carson interview so yes it's
going to be a pretty busy week for
me oh my God so make sure you follow gab
Sanchez on YouTube
youtube.com gab Sanchez or I am gab
sanchez. follow me over there or you can
go to the Tony michaels.com pan all the
way down at the bottom I got that sun
[__] down at the bottom too and if you
want Early Access you want to support me
yeah and you can check out
patreon.com gab
sanchezthe gab Sanchez patreon.com
thanks for thanks for coming by buddy I
appreciate the Bon head of the week I
can't wait to keep doing Bon head of the
week with you I I we keep it going every
single Friday yeah as we do this show
two hours every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 central 9
Pacific on the tubes of you the books of
face the twitch machine and the
instagramy sometimes when I push the
button I didn't push the button today I
didn't get the button pushed it happens
it happens does it happen to you it
happens to me what you should do is come
here same time same place next week surf
sub
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow Tony on
social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after
me [__] them [__]
[Music]
them [__] Tucker Tucker sucks
Murphy's mebn head ass
speaking my
neck neck my neck my back Ney and Trump
crack my neck my back Ney and Trump
crack my neck my back NE Trump crack my
neck will you turkey po your [__] like
this shake your buddy don't stop don't
miss my neck my back neck J neck [__]
and Trump rack my neck my back Ney Trump
cck my neck my back NE Trump crack my
neck my back NE Trump
[Music]
C